how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all but how
that I guess in doubled this is
published in 1958 book by Michael Young
called the rise of the meritocracy he
invented this word and maybe no Michael
Young of course one of the great public
intellectuals of the 20th century the
founder of the Open University etc etc
just a terrific force in 20th century
British life he couldn't he couldn't
publish this book he's very worried
about it and you know he's really
worried about this word meritocracy that
she made up and why I was worried about
it was because it contains a Greek a
word with a Greek root and a word with a
Latin root and you just and he just
mushed them together and he says all
these letters from young so saying I
just don't you people are gonna take it
seriously you know I've just taken a
word of the Latin root and the word of
the Greek root and put it together this
apparently is what troubled social
scientists in the middle of the 20th
century right I don't know how many of
you will be able to tell me what the
Greek and Latin were roots are of the
two words he put together and more
importantly does anyone really care but
the book did get published as a friend
to favorites published as a novel and he
spent the rest of his life writing
letters to the Guardian saying that's
not what I meant every time a politician
used the word including especially Tony
Blair it's a dystopia it's a dystopian
novel it's a it's a book about what
would happen to a society that comes to
believe itself to be a meritocracy and
in some narrow ways to be a meritocracy
if you define merit as having the sorts
of skills and capabilities that will be
rewarded in the labor market it turns
out the people who've got lots of those
skills and capabilities do really well
in the labor market all right and so it
is meritocratic in that sense the very
first sentence of goldman sachs mission
statement is goldman sachs is a
meritocracy I don't know if Michael
Young ever knew that I hope not for his
sake because that's not what I meant is
what he would have written but he
describes a society where IQ plus effort
equals merit and you don't have an
aristocracy anymore but a true
meritocracy of talent why is it a
dystopia because that sounds pretty good
to a lot of people and actually in the
labor market meritocracy has been a
force for good in many ways
particularly in reducing although not
eliminating racial and gender
inequalities four things happen in this
book so if you're not going to read it I
really hope you will I will Tec tell you
the main four takeaways from this book
published sixty years ago this year
number one income inequality
significantly increases once the
meritocracy is established because
unlike in the old society where the
aristocracy was kind of posh people kind
of knew as a lark that got them where
they were they felt they should do
something to actually compensate the
people who are poorer but in a
meritocracy that doesn't happen in a
meritocracy the people are doing really
well are there because of their own
brilliance and their own hard work if
after all your success can be attributed
to your own merit why on earth would you
want to give any of it away why would
you want a 529 plan taken away why would
you want to pay a mansion tax why would
you support increasing inheritance tax
etc why would you be in favor of higher
income taxes because after all you
worked hard for that money in a
meritocracy the result of that is
massively rising income inequality
second thing that happens is the people
who are doing badly in a meritocracy get
increasingly despairing and
disillusioned because it's really hard
to be in a society it keeps telling you
it's a meritocracy when your life is
really hard and you don't feel you're
making any progress because the only
person you can blame is yourself and so
there's huge distance disengagement
disenchantment among the bottom 80% of
his meritocracy the third thing that
happens is that one gets obsessed with
who they're going to marry and have kids
with because after all if you want
meritocratic kids high IQ very well
cultivated you really want to marry
someone else who's highly educated high
IQ and then you can cultivate the kids
together and so the rise of something
called a sort of mating as sociologists
now call it a sort of mating is the
trend whereby you tend to marry and mate
with someone like you educationally
socially etc and in the u.s. now on some
measures people are more likely to marry
across racial lines than they are to
marry across educational lines so in
other words if you have a college degree
in the u.s. you are going to marry
someone else with a college degree you
are actually less like to marry someone
who doesn't have a college degree in
some ways a different race to you
there's this obsession with who you
marry now I'm not suggesting a sort of
Dib mating is a very romantic phrase and
and if any of you are using are those
online based app based dating I wouldn't
say seeking to a sort of lis mate where
fourth thing that happens there is a
populist revolt against the meritocracy
when skillful populist leaders channel
the disenchantment of the losers in the
meritocracy against the meritocratic
elite and it ends in a bloody revolution
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in aaaggghhh